كم هي كثيره الماسي التي طفت بعد الزلزال
المدمر الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا وشمال سوريا
فجر السادس من فبراير الحليب وكثيره هي
ايضا الصور التي وثقت تلك الكارثه التي
حصلت نحو 50 الف قتيل فضلا عن مفقودين تحت
الانقاض الا ان الاثر الذي تركته هذه
الصوره مشاهدينا صوره التركي مسعود هنتشر
ذلك الاب المكلوم الذي جلس فوق الركام
ممسكا يد ابنته المتوفاه تحت الانقاض تكاد
لا تمحى من ذاكره الملايين حول العالم لكن
هذا الرجل المحطم مشاهدينا لقى حمله تضامن
واسعه بعد ان تصدرت صورته وسائل الاعلام
حول العالم وشركها الملايين على مواقع
التواصل وبعد نحو ثلاثه اسابيع من الماساه
غادر هانشر وهو والد لاربعه اطفال غادر
بلدته كرمان مراش ليستقر في انقره حيث قدم
رجل اعمال من العاصمه مسكا له ولاسرته
وعرض موظفا اداريا في القناه التلفزيونيه
التي يملكها